cette fois nous essayons de te faire
oublier
qui tu es
et d'où tu viens
allons te trouver quelque chose qui convienne à un
ami
qu'est-ce que tu penses que je t'ai fait
aimer  loin de chez
moi aussi comment tu as été,
tu sais
prospérer
[Applaudissements]
j'espère qu'un jour nous pourrons parler de pourquoi
tu es vraiment ici
[Musique]
sais-tu pourquoi je suis ici depuis Philadelphie en train de mettre au
rebut le terrain de balle
[Musique]
je suis
devenu méchant maintenant un méchant de philly il
voulait s'occuper de toi
pourquoi déplacer des montagnes pour t'amener ici
alors voici l'histoire
est venue à bel air pour une meilleure éducation
simple
sois patient
donne une vraie chance
nous avons un ensemble de règles différent ici d'
accord
si tu veux bien faire garde la
tête baissée et suis mon exemple oh whoa
whoa mec tu sais  w je suis un philly ouest rouge
où que j'aille yo roi quoi de neuf mec
pas d'amour
regarde autour de
moi ce sont mes gens
ce qu'il faut éviter
bienvenue à bel air
c'est quoi ma vie yo chill out
bro
peut-être que ça ne coupe pas  pour cela
pourquoi travaillons-nous si dur pour sauver un garçon
qui ne veut pas être en sécurité
parce que nous allons vers lui
un vrai homme assume la responsabilité de ses
actes
un vrai homme sait quand abandonner sa
fierté et faire le  le plus d'une seconde
chance
soit la volonté qui a charmé West Philly avec
son talent et son swag laisse la musique désamorcer
toute attention
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de
retour en arrière oh roi de la ville
toi